is who is the bigger badass Batman and
Wolverine which I think they're at the
top of the list of badasses I mean who
do you want to hang out with the guy in
the leather jacket with the mutton chops
that drives up on his Harley or the guy
that comes in the Maserati in the
three-piece suit that gets out of the
car with three different well I don't
attach value to material objects a lot
of what makes Wolverine
it's not a natural power it's a gadget
that's in his body it is a suit
essentially in his body Batman has a
suit Wolverine's powers are not like
Superman's powers where it's like
Superman wore a cape you know what I
mean right am I Am I Wrong Superman's an
alien right going through all the
torture and torment having these
memories put into his brain serving in
the military I think you've been
speaking enough
that's right you stand your ground he's
gonna win the argument because he
doesn't stop